what's our film cards fans we have a
wonderful surprise for you and we are
going to get right to it hello there the
mail has come and somebody it was nice
of them Thunder film we really
appreciate it so we're going to watch
that just a little bit and we also got
this wonderful box from his company
called snorgtees that's s and 0 RG
cheese they make these funny t-shirts
and there are new sponsor so we have
been waiting for this package for some
time we are very excited Mac over at
Shorty's emailed us the other day and
said we'll be sending this wonderful box
so this is like Christmas this is like
Christmas morning we got where we got
this is great here's a man's t-shirt and
it reads if it weren't for law
enforcement and physics I would be
unstoppable yes so this t-shirt will go
to some lucky film courage listener so
pull that up nicely take very good care
of these beautiful shirts and they're
very they're just really nice quality
look at this I think and I me I need to
touch one of them okay yeah you can tell
oh yeah oh yeah I can run in a washing
machine okay wash things oh this is high
quality stuff yeah this is just
beautiful this is catnip yes I can't
hold this for me so this one this one's
another good one it's a man's t-shirt
large and it reads if you don't talk to
them about catnip who will are you sure
guys gonna want this shirt well you know
I mean there are guys out there that
love cats and also there are guys out
there that like girls that like cats and
that's the key so this is a chick magnet
right here this t-shirt okay so it's got
a little picture of a cat on here very
cute all right yeah no I just want to
say you know we have this wonderful box
of t-shirts and we're going to be given
this to film Kurds guests in studio
we're also going to be giving these away
at our film courage interactive
and we'll figure out all the creative
ways to give away oh she's laughing
let's go back to her so this is another
t-shirt that I just love okay this is
man's t-shirt again assistant to the
regional manager so I just just get a
kick out of these t-shirts just you know
I can you imagine wearing this just yeah
I'm the assistant to the regional
manager and it's just like I guess it's
a joke on people who take their titles a
little too seriously so I'm going to
fold this up nicely I know where can you
as my t-shirt in there can you see can
you see that the david brandon t shirt
in here oh wait hang on okay here we go
here's a picture of some cursive writing
and it says third grade lied I never use
cursive sorry just get I get a real kick
out of these shirts all of them are just
so like witty and funny and I got a
couple that are women's sizes in here
that I can't wait to wear we'll get to
those in a second and then your mom goes
to college we did get that your mom goes
i was wondering to get there we actually
got that when your mom goes to college
yep so these are for all of the moms or
training school ok and then check this
out guys this is our cat squeeze look at
this look how adorable look at that an
unbelievable this is what we have to
deal with during the day huh hey
sweetums all right ok back to the
t-shirts this is my tee shirt a shirt ok
and this reads i won the nobel prize in
making delicious pies oh i love it i
love this is so fitting for you so this
is perfect I'm actually getting ready to
make some apple pies tonight yes yeah so
far we're wearing the shirt while he
makes them we have to wrap it up here a
lot of words here we go here we go
here's a ladies shirt for all of our
lady film crews listeners strangers have
the best candy just love it so we'll
show you some more shirts in a little
bit we have
wonderful care package that he sent for
us and can't wait to wear them and
especially can't wait to give her away
to sell the listeners so stay tuned
everybody snorgtees snort is calm
you